hey guys it's katie and i have been
seeing this jiji hadid
spicy vodka pasta all over the internet
and it looks really really good so i
want to try it but then i also want to
try
to make my own vodka sauce and see whose
is better i definitely am not going to
beat ggm modeling
or being cool she's awesome but maybe i
can beat her at cooking
guess who the wine taste tester is going
to be
it's chris hey i love food and i love
testing it
are you ready to like risk our marriage
yes when you choose
absolutely as long as you get past as
long as i get pasta i'm willing to lose
everything let's get cooking
we'll first get started with gigi's
recipe hearst calls for you to heat up a
quarter cup of olive oil
which seems like a lot of oil but i
trust gigi once that's hot you'll add a
quarter of a shallot
finely diced and one clove of garlic
also finely diced
you'll cook that until the shallot is
nice and tender my kitchen already
smells so good this would definitely
make a great date night dinner once your
shallots are soft and translucent
she has you add a quarter cup of tomato
paste which is fairly traditional in a
vodka sauce recipe
she has you cook that until the tomato
paste darkens and everything gets a
little caramelized
it's looking so good now it's time to
add one tablespoon of vodka
in her instagram post she actually
excluded the vodka because she didn't
have any at home so this part is
definitely optional
you want to cook that vodka until it's
almost completely gone
you can see the steam coming into my
camera that's the vodka evaporating
after that she has you add a half a cup
of heavy cream and this is really what
makes vodka sauce
so luscious and delicious and i almost
forgot the red pepper flakes
she has you add an entire teaspoon of
red pepper flakes
which does seem like a lot but she did
call this a spicy vodka sauce
you'll then stir that until it's
completely combined the sauce looks
really creamy and rich so far i'm
impressed
once combined she says to season with
salt and pepper she doesn't say how much
so i'm just seasoning it to my taste
it's definitely a thick sauce that is
really going to coat the pasta nicely
next you'll remove the sauce from the
heat while you cook your pasta
traditionally penne pasta is used with
this kind of sauce but jiji uses half a
pound of orecchiette which i actually
really like and think will hold on to
her sauce well
gigi also has you reserve a quarter cup
of pasta water which we'll use in a
moment to help loosen up the thick sauce
i promise i'm not throwing it down the
sink it is going into a colander once
strained you'll add the pasta into the
sauce with your reserved pasta water and
one tablespoon of butter
gigi's exact directions at this point is
to stir until
the sauce is saucy and this is looking
pretty saucy to me
and everything is coated very nicely
last thing she has you add is a quarter
cup of grated parmesan and any
additional salt and pepper if you need
it
so really just season this to taste this
recipe is for two people
and she serves it garnished with more
parmesan cheese
i love the cheese and some chopped basil
and there you have it gigi's spicy vodka
sauce i'm impressed
next we're gonna make mine i cook my
pasta before i start making my sauce
because i'm not great at multitasking
and also i won't have to remove my sauce
from the heat later on
for my recipe i cook half a pound of
penne pasta i also reserve some pasta
water for later on just in case my sauce
gets too thick
now it's time to start on our actual
sauce i began heating up a large
saucepan over medium heat
once hot i had finely diced bacon
this is my secret ingredient and i'm
hoping it's just going to give my sauce
that edge it needs to win i cook the
bacon just until the edges start to
crisp a little bit
and if your bacon isn't particularly
fatty you can add a tablespoon of butter
like i'm doing here
and right now it smells like saturday
morning in my house once the bacon is a
little crispy i add an entire shallot
finely diced
like gigi but just way more i love the
sweetness of a shallot and think it's a
really great choice for this sauce i'll
cook that for about three to four
minutes until the shallots are tender
and then add a half a teaspoon of red
pepper flakes
i do this now so it can bloom in the oil
and ensure you get an even spice in
every bite
i also add four cloves of minced garlic
four
i love garlic you can really never have
enough like
really seriously i love garlic once your
garlic is fragrant and really smell it
add three tablespoons of vodka
and just like gigi i'll cook this until
almost all of it evaporates and what the
vodka is doing is it's deglazing the pan
and it's adding a bit of a bite to our
sauce
next i add crushed san marzano tomatoes
that i've run through a strainer i use
these tomatoes instead of tomato paste
because they're super flavorful
and just i think they're going to
brighten up this rich creamy sauce
tomato paste on the other hand has this
very deep bold flavor
which is great but i think can sometimes
overwhelm a dish
we'll bring this to a simmer and cook
until the sauce has thickened and
i can run my spoon along the bottom of
the pan and it leaves a trail behind it
next i'll add a half a cup of heavy
cream just like gigi and i'll stir until
incorporated but unlike gigi's i will
not be removing the pan from the heat
instead i'll let it cook on a low simmer
for about five minutes until it's
thickened up a bit
finally i'll add in the penne with a
little bit of butter and because my
sauce isn't too thick i won't be using
any of the reserved pasta water
we'll turn off the heat and add a half a
cup mixture of grated parmesan and
romano cheese
i find romano to be a little tangier
than parmesan so it just adds some more
depth of flavor to the sauce
for garnish i go big and i like to serve
with some torn burrata a little olive
oil and some freshly ground pepper
and to balance the dish we'll add a
little chopped basil
and that's my panela vodka so i've made
both dishes
they both look really good and honestly
like chris could definitely
pick gigi's they both smell amazing i'm
hoping mine wins
our marriage depends on it let's go do
the taste test all right chris
here you are your two pastas these look
really good i'm gonna stand really close
to you and just make you nervous
the pressure is mounting uh all right
i'm gonna try
this one with the what is this penne
first i like this i like the look of it
i like this cheese what kind of cheese
is this that is burrata
i like that it tastes a little bit rich
it's got a nice spice to it but it's not
too spicy
i like it i'm gonna try this one now
this one looks fancier to me
this one's really good too uh it's got a
nice kick to it it might even be a
little bit spicier too
i think my favorite
is the penne really yeah wait are you
kidding i thought you were about to pick
cheese
that's mine yes i was like no which is
like hers is
really good gigi great job on yours that
pasta really was delicious
and let us know in the comments guys if
you have your own little twist
on the penne alla vodka or which one you
would have rather you're not going to
hurt my feelings
and yeah until next time we'll see you
around
bye bye i didn't pay him typically
she did not but but it helped our
marriage that he did
it we survive another day
yeah this was really tasty oh yay i'm
glad you liked it
[Music]
you